estamos en pleno centro estoy en pleno
centro del frente en ir pin los tanques
están aquí
en los kilómetros que he recorrido junto
a los combatientes que me han permitido
entrar hay toda una población dedicada a
resistir x horas de bucky todavía hay
familias que están en bunkers
y realmente es una ciudad entera en modo
de resistencia
realmente estamos en pleno frente
bueno
sol
tienen esos humos negros son los ataques
de artillería de tanques activa
y este tractor fue reconvertido o toque
por la 12a de decidir en tanque para
poder avanzar junto a los civiles y es
aquí donde me encuentro este esta es
exactamente la línea de frente en la
avenida principal de el pino donde
pudimos avanzar junto a estos
combatientes se debe a que todavía hay
muchos civiles que continúan evacuando y
hay tiradores de élite rusos que están a
unos 500 metros de donde me encuentro es
una zona muy complicada
en pleno corazón del pino
pues sí aquí es exactamente donde están
avanzando las fuerzas rusas y dónde
están los combatientes y la resistencia
de ir ping en este frente del noroeste
que están listos para recibir
y para resistir
esa ciudad es atacada
permanentemente y estamos del lado que
aún está controlado por las fuerzas
ucranianas
pero los tanques rusos que están a un
centenar de metros de donde me encuentro
yo y la situación es muy tensa y aquí
justo frente a mí están las arterias de
la ciudad sobre mí de los famosos
kilómetros que llevan hacia kiev donde
continúan refugiándose muchos residentes
que todavía están bloqueados de este
lado de la ciudad